from subtle references to Stephen King's
other work to the use of baby food for
an unexpected special effect there are
plenty of things you probably failed to
notice in the Shawshank Redemption the
Shawshank Redemption is full of small
references and clues that hardly anyone
would notice on first viewing but on
subsequent re-watches you'll be
wondering how they passed you by one of
these is a very early hint about exactly
how Andy would escape the prison at one
point the contents of Andy cell are
being tossed around by Captain Hadley
and Warden Norton as they check for
Contraband the room is completely
trashed with Andy's belongings on the
floor the bed flipped over and the bear
coming close to discovering the secret
tunnel he's been digging in the wall
when the warden finds Andy's Bible the
two discuss their faith and then talk
about their favorite verses from the
good book
I almost forgot
I'd hate to deprive you of this
salvation lies within
this turns out to be foreshadowing the
fact that Andy has in fact hidden his
rock hammer inside the Bible as well as
the words being found in the Bible
Andy's salvation the tool he will use to
escape also lies hidden within the pages
escaping from Shawshank State
Penitentiary is never far from Andy's
mind and there is another brief quote
from a character in The Shawshank
Redemption that offers a clue to the way
he eventually breaks out while having a
conversation just before his escape
attempt and he talks to Red about his
plans for when he gets out of prison the
two prisoners speak about the future and
Andy reveals that he wants to travel to
Mexico and live in the country when he's
on the outside but red tells him he
shouldn't waste his time dreaming of
things that will never happen I don't
think he ought to be doing this to
yourself Andy this is a shitty pipe
dreams when Andy does escape from the
prison it is of course via a method that
is referenced in Red's dialogue he
crawls through hundreds of yards of
human excrement in a sewage pipe and his
pipe dream of escaping does come true
after all red of course is played by the
great Morgan Freeman Red becomes fast
friends with Andy and the two grow
closer and closer throughout the film
however the character is a bit different
in the original Stephen King Novella in
that story while red is still the prison
fixer who sources the rock hammer for
Andy he's also a white Irish man with
red hair the character's name makes
sense in the story but red doesn't match
quite as well for the depiction of him
in the film the movie reveals at one
point that his real name is actually
Ellis Boyd reading giving a clear reason
for why he uses red as a nickname
however when Andy asks him about his
moniker red simply replies
maybe it's because I'm Irish
this cheeky joke would be lost in the
vast majority of viewers but if you know
about the original story then it's a
really fun reference of the more than 80
novels that Stephen King has written
over the course of his career there is
usually one main constant the vast
majority of them are set in the state of
Maine the place of the author's birth
and the area where he still lives it's
perfectly understandable then that the
original story Rita Hayworth and
Shawshank Redemption takes place in
Maine just like most of his other
stories and when it came to adapting the
novella for film director Frank Darabont
chose to keep the setting the same
however if you have watched The
Shawshank Redemption multiple times then
something could have jumped out as
unusual that's because none of the
characters in the film speak with a main
accent despite the fact that a good deal
of the characters in the prison should
be from Maine the only character with
the hint of an accent is the warden but
even that is only very slight there
should be a lot more people speaking as
if they're actually from Maine but
luckily this oversight doesn't really
detract from the story even those who
have seen the Shawshank Redemption just
once might notice that there is a
distinct lack of women throughout the
entire film in many ways it shouldn't be
all that surprising that most of the
characters in The Shawshank Redemption
are meant since the vast majority of the
action takes place in Shawshank State
Penitentiary a prison for male inmates
this means that all of the prisoners are
men and the staff are also male to
ensure that they stay safe leaving very
little opportunity for speaking rules
for women there are just two
female-speaking roles in the Shawshank
Redemption for those who are looking
closely one is the bank teller played by
Claire slemmer who speaks to Andy after
he escapes from prison and requests some
cash the other is a customer played by
Dana Snyder who tells Brooks to double
bag her shopping when he is working in
the store even Andy's wife who is shown
during a flashback sequence at the start
of the movie doesn't talk during the
brief time she is on screen
Brooks is one of the few prisoners in
the Shawshank Redemption outside of
Andean red who has given significant
screen time one of the oldest inmates in
Shawshank State Penitentiary he is put
in charge of the library and later
befriends Andy when he's transferred to
work with the books as well the two Bond
over their love of fiction and the fact
they are both Highly Educated when Andy
finds a maggot in his prison food Brooks
asks if he can have the insect so he can
feed it to Jake an injured bird he is
secretly caring for however it wasn't a
real maggot the American Society for the
prevention of cruelty to animals
objected to an insect being fed to the
bird entirely for filming purposes as
they don't allow any living creatures to
be killed for a movie according to
Humane Hollywood this maggot was
actually fashioned from baby food to
give it the appearance of an insect
larva and make it edible for the crow
which was carefully placed in the
actor's pocket by an animal Handler the
Shawshank Redemption takes place over
quite a long period of time according to
Red Andy first arrives in Shawshank
State penitentiary in the year 1947 and
doesn't escape the walls of the facility
until 1966. that means that the film
takes place over the course of some 19
years this passage of time is made
perfectly clear to the audience so if it
isn't like the filmmakers are trying to
disguise the fact that so many years
have passed but despite almost two
decades passing during the story none of
the characters in The Shawshank
Redemption show any signs of aging
whatsoever red Andy and the others all
look the same near the conclusion of the
film as they do right at the start of
the action they should have aged by some
20 years in that time and at least
demonstrates some evidence that they are
now much older than they were yet for
some reason they don't in Stephen King's
novels the number 217 has appeared
several times it was most famously the
number of the guest room at the Overlook
Hotel where Lorraine Massey had died by
Suicide an event that played an integral
part in The Narrative of The Shining
however when Stanley Kubrick adapted the
book to the hit film in 1980 he changed
the room number to 237 seemingly at the
request of the lodge where they filmed
that so that visitors were would not
want to avoid the room in real life a
call back to this important number is
made in the Shawshank Redemption
although it is only briefly mentioned
and could easily be missed by anyone
watching the movie for the first time
red cell and Shawshank State
Penitentiary is number 237 revealed when
the guards are searching for the missing
Andy there is little doubt that this is
no coincidence and was intended as an
Easter egg for those who are big fans of
King's wider work
open two three seven
[Music]
as the Shawshank Redemption progresses
we find out more about the past of some
of the characters one consistent theme
that's present throughout the film is
red attending a parole hearing to
determine whether he has rehabilitated
and is fit to re-enter Society over the
course of the two decades that are
portrayed in the movie Red attends three
different parole hearings before he's
finally approved and allowed to leave
Shawshank State Penitentiary after
spending 40 years behind bars during
these hearings a folder showing Red's
prison file is on display it shows the
rejected stamp Mark and information
about the character this includes a
photograph of red and his youth when he
was first put in prison the picture used
isn't just a random younger man but
someone that looks very like the actor
Morgan Freeman and there's a very good
reason for that the person in the
photograph is actually Morgan Freeman's
son Alfonso Freeman who also plays a
convict in the prison during the early
parts of the film It's Not Unusual for
directors to occasionally have a role in
their films sometimes as small as just
showing their hands for example Quentin
Tarantino famously used his hands both
off camera and on camera in Kill Bill
and in glorious bastards specifically he
used them in scenes where actors needed
to be choked feeling that only he could
pull off such a delicate process a
similar thing happens in the Shawshank
Redemption with director Frank darabon
acting as a hand double for Tim Robbins
character according to the DVD
commentary for the film The Director
used his own hands for insert shots when
Andy was handling a revolver or any
other close-ups of the character's hands
as Darabont felt that he could perform
the required motions more accurately
than Robins could it also saved time and
effort to Simply perform the actions
himself since only the most eagle-eyed
viewers would ever notice the hands are
different along with the reference to
The Shining the Shawshank Redemption
also includes a variety of other Easter
eggs related to Stephen King's novels or
film and television adaptations of his
work one of the more obvious is the
Alias that Andy uses while doing the the
taxes of the warden the Alias of course
is very important to the story as it
gives Andy the opportunity not only to
hide his illicit activities on behalf of
the warden but also to withdraw the
hidden money from several Banks after he
escapes from prison in King's original
story The Alias used as Peter Stevens
but in the movie Andy invents the name
Randall Stevens which is a nod to the
supernatural villain Randall Flagg from
various novel series written by King
including the stand and The Dark Tower
Frank Darabont admitted he changed the
original name from Peter to Randall and
homage to the author without telling the
legal team or the rest of the crew who
the silent silent partner
he's the guilty one your honor the man
with the bank accounts few people would
have complaints about Tim Robbins
performance in the Shawshank Redemption
in fact it would be difficult to imagine
anyone else taking on the role of Andy
in the film especially when you consider
the other fantastic actors who are part
of the movie as well however having
Robins portray Andy did introduce some
rather interesting problems for director
Frank Darabont the actor is
significantly taller than most people
standing at an impressive six feet five
inches that makes him around four inches
taller than his co-star Morgan Freeman
and a full head larger than most of the
cast with Andy not meant to be an
especially imposing figure the
filmmakers had to use some movie Magic
to make it seem as if Robbins was
actually shorter than he really is the
way this was achieved is remarkably
simple and something the audiences
likely would pay very little attention
to at least on the first viewing
Darabont just had Robin's rarely stand
up straight so that almost every scene
involving Andy sees the character either
sitting down or leaning to one side this
gave the illusion that he was actually a
similar height to every everyone else